un verre d'alcool ok on a un sentiment
de détente effectivement on peut sentir
l'usada cieux pour pour draguer une
personne ou même pour expérimenter des
choses on lit mais en réalité très vite
en fait il faut pas beaucoup de verts
2,3 vers déjà et la bes a peut être
déclencheur d'une désinhibition mais qui
nous amène à de la violence alors si on
en boit plusieurs toute la mécanique
masculine et féminine pas vraiment
réagir au ralenti ça veut dire quoi mais
plus de difficultés pour l'homme à avoir
une érection et de grandes chances de ne
pas arriver jusqu'à l'éjaculation est
pour la femme
pareil donc la lubrification vaginale va
- ce père l'érection de notre clitoris
et s'il a fait des pancartes qui ne sert
pour l'instant la question alors la
question est simple est-ce que vous êtes
choqués ou non mais non cette émission à
15 heures même si c'est mis sur la sont
extrêmement utiles je suis absolument
certain mais est ce que ça vous choque à
15 heures qu'on vient d'entendre ça me
paraît ça me parait limitrophes mais bon
christine alors c'est pas c'est dans la
pédagogie
je trouve que c'est pas vulgaire c'est
dans l'explication
la csa s'est posé des questions si ce
qu'on y avait brigitte là et à la radio
etc
donc on est toujours dans la pédagogie
après lorsqu'on va dans la vulgarité
on est obligé de passer ces émissions
une femme est d'accord d'accord je suis
d'accord mais imaginez moi j'ai plus
d'enfants qui sont petits mais alors à
l'enfant de taille à 15 heures ils sont
pas en examen sinon il peut être le
mercredi nous visions d'un je termine
par exemple aujourd'hui un sexologue dit
qu'en moyenne à 8 ans un enfant avait
une image pornographique
je pense qu'il ne faut pas éluder ces
questions à la télévision je pense qu'il
faut parler franchement de ces questions
il ne faut par les enfants soient
éduqués sur les réseaux sociaux à
l'école par d'autres camarades éolien il
faut qu'on pas clairement des questions
l'équipe et le psychiatre a raison qui
connaît bien ce problème qui maintenant
on va dire oui un vrai problème de la
pornographie qui rentrent de plus en
plus tôt dans les écoles avec les
portables
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui enfants accès
à des images en un clic
oui à dégueulasse on may a fait un vrai
souci pour les ados d'aujourd'hui
surtout les garçons qui effectivement
très tôt chez
à consommer donc c'est important que les
parents leur dise à ces ados attendait
d'être plus grand d'avoir déjà des
vraies relations sexuelles dans la vie
avant de consommer du porno parce
qu'après on devient addict au porno et
le sexe réel ne devient-il et il ya eu
des études qui ont montré qu aujourd'hui
la sexualité des jeunes était en train
de changer
oui et qui est dans un schéma de
reproduction de films oui et que ça
commence à laisser ses seins ça
commençait à poser des problèmes c'est
vrai ça c'est vrai c'est vrai certains
d'entre eux mais c'est vrai aussi pour
d'autres au contraire ça va complètement
les inhiber c'est à dire qu'ils vont ils
ont pu oser où ils vont plus avoir envie
c'est à dire que le porno suffit pour
les satisfaire et d'ailleurs cet
argument c'est valable si reconduit aux
ados ne regarde pas du porno parce que
je veux que tu as une vie sexuelle plus
tard plutôt que leur faire croire qu'on
veut les empêcher d'avoir accès à la
sexualité gêne c'est choquant je suis
désolé était désolé aussi que christine
donne quitus à l'émission parce que sous
couvert effectivement de d'une pseudo
pédagogie c'est du sexe ne sait pas
faire de il explique les choses du sexe
lui a offert de l'audience à ces vases
la crise' et moi je suis désolé c'est le
service public non payer une redevance
mais je ne paye pas une redevance pour
des émissions de 5 après leur travail et
voilà j'ai écouté skyrock c'est papa
mais je sais pas 15 heures c'est vrai
n'ont pas capitalisé moi c'était un pur
dizaine de fois c'est pas du tout du
même disque du même registre il faut
quand même parler clairement de ces
choses là et c'est justement tous les
spécialistes disent que il faut parler
normalement même un enfant de 8 ans et
je suis avec comme un adulte
et ça c'est le but des émissions comme
ça et nikola est ce que ça vous choque
ça bah oui moi c'est ce qui me dérange
c'est surtout quand on
voilà qu'on parle de sujets différents
au sujet du sexe on peut parler de la
pédagogie pour apprendre un petit peu
voilà aux enfants un petit peu cet
univers mais de là à donner toutes les
ficelles de du sexe je pense que c'est
une polémique pour cet horaire là mais
ça mais c'est une émission au service du
public et je me suis renseigné sur l'âge
moyen de cette émission elle est de 62 à
oui j'ai vu ma vie passée je vais
demander à raymond qui a découvert très
tôt les films pornographiques
oui moi je suis pro d'abord je suis le
pro 2 autour de la table c'est moi le
proco derrière toi je vais à christine
il faut pas laisser les autres faire
l'éducation
là j'aurai petit un petit bémol panne
mercredi les amis le mercredi nous
appeler parce que pourquoi qu'est ce qui
se passe si on laisse les autres faire
l'éducation
on a tous été sur les sites à pourvoir
pour l'un mais sinon investigations et
m'a donné des noms de sites j'ai
halluciné le nombre de sites qui peut y
apparaît et il ya toujours cette
question car ils jettent étonné par la
question avez-vous banon je suis pas
majeur pas vraiment que le monde de 8 10
ans demandé christine il va dire ah bah
non je suis pas majeur on arrête on a
réfléchi
on parle du fait d'évoquer le sexe non
mais ce sont des crises libérer alors
été pédagogique
allez disons à une heure de grande
écoute à 15h ou non labellisés bio
choqué alors oui je suis choquée mais
extrêmement choquée je pense que vous
réalisez pas moi j'ai trois enfants à la
maison d'accord je suis là je suis maman
je fais des crêpes le mercredi
après-midi et les opérations et jacques
ulation coopération avec de l'alcool
c'est mieux on ait pu libérer compétents
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
avec moi ça de façon sûre et brut de
décoffrage mais quoi
et toi élan et voir ce à quoi nos
enfants ont accès à ces vidéos via une
caméra quelques par magali des séries
américaines les deux heures plus mère
elle se réveille pas
[Applaudissements]